The Importance of Communication.
There might be nothing more important than efficient communication in the success of a company.
For example, if an organization has a great product,...
...it won't be able to sell it without communicating the product to the greater world.
Within an organization, interpersonal communication skills are critical to the success of the company,...
...from management down and vice versa.
However, despite the importance of communication,...
...it is largely agreed that not everyone is cut out for effective communication.
A very bright scientist may have all the confidence in the world when it comes to studying atomic particles in his lab,...
...but ask him to present the status of his project to management...
...and he might be totally worried about his inability to communicate his ideas publicly.
Likewise, an effective manager skilled at public speaking...
...may be ill at ease when confronted with a one-on-one interview with a subordinate.
A secretary skilled at answering phones and handling disgruntled people...
...may be uncomfortable when told she will be required to stand at the upcoming luncheon...
...and introduce herself to everyone.
Let's face it,...
...communication is a universal skill requirement in all facets of life.